As a warm-up towards finding
the distribution of the
function of random variables,
let us start by considering
the discrete case.
So let X be a discrete random
variable and let Y be defined
as a given function of X. We
know the PMF of X and wish to
find the PMF of Y. Here's
a simple example.
The random variable X takes the
values 2, 3, 4, and 5 with
the probabilities given in the
figure, and Y is the function
indicated here.
Then, for example, the
probability that Y takes a
value of 4.
This is also the value of the
PMF of Y evaluated at 4.
This is simply the sum of the
probabilities of the possible
values of X that give
rise to a value of Y
that is equal to 4.
Therefore, this expression is
equal to the probability that
X equals to 4 plus the
probability that
X is equal to 5.
Or, in PMF notation, we can
write it in this manner.
And in this numerical example,
it would be 0.3 plus 0.4.
More generally, for any given
value of little y, the
probability that the random
variable capital Y takes this
particular value is the sum of
the probabilities of the
little x that result in
that particular value.
So the probability that the
random variable capital Y,
which is the same as g of X,
takes on a specific value is
the sum of the probabilities
of all possible values of
little x where we only consider
those values of
little x that give rise to the
specific value, little y, that
you're interested.
Let us now look into the special
case where we have a
linear function of a discrete
random variable.
Suppose that X is described by
the PMF shown in this diagram,
and let us consider the random
variable Z, which is defined
as 2 times X. We would like
to plot the PMF of Z.
First, let us note the values
that Z can take.
When X is equal to minus
1, Z is going to be
equal to minus 2.
When X is equal to 1, Z is
going to be equal to 2.
And when X is equal to 2, Z
is going to be equal to 4.
This event that X is equal
to minus 1 happens with
probability 2/6, and when that
event happens, Z will take a
value of minus 2.
So this event happens with
probability 2/6.
With probability 1/6, X takes a
value of 1 so that Z takes a
value of 2.
And this happens with
probability 1/6.
6 And finally, this last
event here happens
with probability 3/6.
We have thus found the PMF of Z.
Notice that it has the same
shape as the PMF of X, except
that it is stretched or scaled
horizontally by a factor of 2.
Let us now consider the random
variable Y, defined as 2X plus
3, or what is the same
as Z plus 3.
With probability 2/6, Z
is equal to minus 2.
And in that case, Y is going
to be equal to plus 1.
And this event happens
with probability 2/6.
With probability 1/6, Z takes
a value of 2 so that Y it
takes a value of 5.
And finally, with probability
3/6, Z takes a value of 4 so
that Y it takes a value of 7.
What we see here is that the PMF
of Y has exactly the same
shape as the PMF of Z, except
that it is shifted to the
right by 3.
To summarize, in order to find
the PMF of a linear function
such as 2X plus 3, what we do
is that we first stretch the
PMF of X by a factor of
2 and then shift it
horizontally by 3.
We can also describe the PMF
of Y through a formula.
For any given value of little
y, the PMF is going to be
equal to the probability that
our random variable Y takes on
the specific value little y.
Then we recall that Y has been
defined in our example to be
equal to 2X plus 3, so we're
looking at the probability of
this event.
But this is the same as the
event that X takes a value
equal to y minus
3 divided by 2.
And in PMF notation, we can
write it in this form.
So what this is saying is that
the probability that Y takes
on a specific value is the same
as the probability that X
takes on some other
specific value.
And that value here is that
value of X that would give
rise to this particular
value little y.
Now, we can generalize the
calculation that we just did.
And more generally, if we have
a linear function of a
discrete random variable X, the
PMF of the random variable
Y is given by this formula in
terms of the PMF of the random
variable X. The derivation
is the same.
We use b instead the specific
number 3, and we have a
general constant a instead
of the 2 that
we had in this example.
And this formula describes
exactly what we did
graphically in our
previous example.
This factor of a here serves to
stretch the PMF by a factor
of a, and this term b here
serves to shift the PMF by b.